[Music]
my dad he
died I'm the solicitor of your father's
estate my dad owned this
place I don't have any memories with him
this is all I have right
now if you're watching this then I'm
already
[Music]
dead this property comes with a special
tenant
you're the one thing that stands between
her and the outside world you're
joking what is that come out come out
whereever you
[Applause]
all
Iris we shouldn't be
here
what is
she she has the power to bring back the
Dead I want to see her money's really no
object I want to talk to my
wife she only gives you 2
minutes sah after that she's in
control what's going
on we are not safe
here how do I control
her this isn't something you can
[Music]
control
I'm going to kill you you can't kill
her you cannot let her out of the
basement